[Music]  in fact  many fans had already been looking  forward to the mortal kombat movie which  was supposed to release in the coming  march  on twitter producer todd garner now  reached out to the fans with bad news  since the reboot will not be able to  appear as planned due to the cinema  closures  according to garner there will be a new  date only after it is clear when cinemas  can open again  the same applies to a long-awaited  trailer thus mortal kombat judged on  numerous films that have no release date  since their postponements  it is to be hoped that the production  team will use the time for fine tuning  and will be able to offer the fans an  even better cinema experience in the end  [Music]  you